do you think about your own mortality
are you afraid of it
yes but I I keep going back to my idea
of being able to expand
human life
quickly enough
uh in advance of our getting there
longevity escape velocity
um
which we're not quite at yet
but I think we're actually pretty close
uh particularly with for example doing
simulated biology
I think we can probably get there within
say by the end of this decade
and that's my goal you hope to achieve
the longevity escape velocity do you
hope to achieve immortality
well immortality is hard to say I can't
really come on your program saying I've
done it I've achieved immortality right
because it's never forever
um
a long time a long time of living well
but we'd like to actually Advance human
life expectancy Advance my life
expectancy more than a year every year
and I think we can get there within by
the end of this decade
how do you think we do it
so there's practical things
um
and transcend the nine steps to living
well forever your book you describe just
that there's practical things like
Health exercise all those things I mean
we live in a body that doesn't last
forever
there's no reason why it can't though
and we're discovering things I think
that will extend it
um
but you do have to deal with I mean I've
got various issues
went to Mexico
40 years ago
developed salmonella they created
pancreatitis
which gave me a strange form of diabetes
um it's not
uh type 1 diabetes because that's an
autoimmune disorder that destroys your
pancreas I don't have that
but it's also not type 2 diabetes
because type 2 diabetes is your pancreas
works fine but your cells don't absorb
the insulin well I don't have that
either
the pancreatitis I had
partially damaged my pancreas but it was
a one-time thing it didn't continue
and I've learned now how to control it
but so that's just something that I had
to do
uh in order to
continue to exist since your particular
biological system you have to figure out
a few hacks and the idea is that science
would be yes you have to do that much
better actually yeah so I mean I do
spend a lot of time just tinkering with
my own body to keep it going
uh so I do think I'll last till the end
of this decade and I think we'll achieve
longevity escape velocity
I think that will start with people who
are very diligent about this
eventually it'll become sort of routine
that that people will be able to do it
so if you're talking about
kids today or even people in their 20s
to 30s it's really not a very serious
problem
I have had some discussions with
relatives who were
like almost a hundred
and saying well we're working on it as
quickly as possible but I don't know if
that's going to work
is there a case this is a difficult
question but is there a case
to be made against living forever that
a finite life that mortality is a
feature not a bug
that that living a shorter so dying
makes ice cream taste delicious
makes life intensely beautiful more than
uh you know people believe that way
except if you present a death of anybody
they
care about or love
they find that extremely depressing
and I know people who feel that way
20 30 40
years later they still want them back
um
so I mean death is not
something to celebrate
but we've lived in a world where people
just accept this well life is short you
see it all the time on TV uh life short
you have to take advantage of it and
nobody accepts the fact that you can
actually go beyond normal lifetimes
but anytime we talk about death or death
of a person even one death is a terrible
tragedy
if you have somebody that lives 200
years old we still
love them in in return
and there's no limit
limitation to that in fact these kinds
of uh Trends are going to provide
greater and greater opportunity for
everybody even if we have more people
so let me ask about an alien species or
super intelligent AI 500 years from now
that will look back
and remember Ray Kurzweil version zero
the uh before the replicants spread uh
how do you hope they remember you
in a um Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
summary of Ray Kurzweil what do you hope
your legacy is
well I mean I do hope to be around so
that's some version of you yes so
um do you think you'll be the same
person around I mean am I the same
person I was when I was that's true
you would be the same person in that
same way but yes we're different
we're doing um
all we have of that all you have of that
person is your memories which are
probably
um
distorted in some way
maybe you just remember the good parts
depending on your psyche
you might focus on the bad parts might
focus on the good parts
right but I mean I still have a
relationship to the way I was when I was
earlier when I was younger
how will you and the other super
intelligent AIS remember you of today
from 500 years ago
what do you hope to be remembered by
this version of you
before the singularity
well I think it's expressed well in my
books trying to
create some new realities that people
will accept I mean that's something that
gives me great pleasure
um
and great greater insight into what what
makes humans
uh valuable
I'm not the only person who's
uh attempted to
comment on that but
and uh optimism that permeates your work
optimism about the future
it's all to me that optimism paves the
way for building a better future yeah I
I agree with that
so you uh asked
your dad about the meaning of life and
he said love
let me ask you the same question
what's the meaning of life
why are we here
this beautiful Journey that we're on
in phase
Force reaching for phase five
of this evolutionary information
processing why
well I think I'd get the same answers as
my father
um
because if there was no love and we
didn't care about anybody
there'd be no point existing
love is the meaning of life the AI
version of your dad had a good point
well I think that's a beautiful way to
end it right thank you for your work
thank you for being who you are thank
you for dreaming about a beautiful
future and uh creating it along the way
and thank you so much for
spending your really valuable time with
me today this was awesome well it was my
pleasure and you have some great
insights
nothing to me and into Humanity as well
so I appreciate that